finland's border with its Russian
neighbor runs over 1300 kilometers
through the rugged tiger
peace has rained here for decades but
ever since Russia invaded Ukraine
nothing has been the same as perty
permanent and pekakunas tell it
both say that peace is threatened but
they don't quite agree on who's to blame
for that
I don't trust the Russians Europe should
have presented a unified front much
sooner I feel sorry for the Ukrainian
people
we're attacking the Russians ourselves
by supplying arms to Ukraine to the
Russians we're the enemy now
only two months before parity permanent
and his wife had taken over running this
little hotel in barcilla
they've had guests but not enough to get
by they missed the Russian summer
visitors and party poormanin likes the
people from across the border
he's been to Russia many times both
privately and on business and he says
Moscow is not the only one to blame for
the current situation
we're worried because finland's foreign
policy is getting more and more
aggressive toward the East that worries
me we can only hope we'll be spared and
the Russian missiles will pass over us
if they launch them someday
pekakuna speaks Russian as well but
unlike his neighbor he'd rather not see
any more Russians in varzilla he says he
used to keep an eye out for four-legged
Predators here in the area
but today it's the two-legged kind that
worry him more
from this sign it's only 150 meters to
the international border
we feel as if we are constantly Facing a
Giant Predator
we're not afraid but we have to keep a
constant eye on this predator
but for now Life Goes On Kunis is
looking forward to the traditional
classic car show in the next town
elomancy like every year
as a retired firefighter he's
particularly proud of his 1960s vintage
fire truck from an era when the cold war
between East and West was raging
finland's corellia has always been a
frontier region
today the border is also the edge of the
European Union and the Schengen area
soon it'll be NATO's longest continuous
border with Russia
many here are wondering how that will
affect relations with their neighbors
will Russian tourists still be allowed
to cross over freely Russians have
applied for nearly 60 000 visas to
Finland since the start of 2022 most
intending to travel onwards now many EU
members would like to see this gate to
Western Europe closed insisting that
Russians can't be allowed to vacation in
the west while they're Waging War in
Europe
others ask why not
the responsibility for the war can't be
laid on all Russians
it's even a topic of debate at the car
show
it would be good if Ordinary People
realize what kind of government they've
got
it's a general rule
as is the government so are the people
one country has attacked another
sovereign state so it's only right to
limit the number of Russians here as a
way of imposing sanctions
I just hope it can help improve the
situation
they shouldn't close the border when
Russians come over here they get another
fresh perspective they're living in a
closed society
and right now they're only getting a
one-sided version of things
businesses in Finland are already
feeling the Steep decline in Russian
tourists
I'm hoping reason will Triumph and we
can find great States people who can
work the matter out amongst themselves
what's important is that we can live
close to the Border in peace and not
have to worry about what might come from
over there in the unknown East
but the damage has been done to
neighborly relations between Finland and
Russia
and it's unlikely to be undone for many
years
in a region that shares a thousand
kilometer long border